a LAN boc kidding easy and that what he
do for living out i'm a senior editorial
writer for the Orange County Register
newsman yeah and you're are you a
medical marijuana no no you just write
about is that one of your things right
about one of the things i right about
it's our dedit oriole policy is
generally libertarian and so we've
supported drug law reform for a long
time but when proposition 215 was on the
ballot in 1996 we supported it and did
fairly extensive study of the various
ramification so we thought we could make
a fairly persuasive case for it then
after it was passed I was the editorial
writer that they said you know keep an
eye on how it's being implemented and I
did several covers of the commentary
section on implementation and places
where it was being implemented
satisfactorily and most places where it
wasn't being and that grew into the book
that I wrote on the politics of medical
marijuana the controlled substance act
was passed in 73 or 74 and it
establishes five schedules for drugs
that are controlled that can be done
only with the cooperation of a doctor
and a pharmacy schedule one is is
completely prohibited LSD heroin and
marijuana are on schedule one doctor
already no doctor no nothing is there's
no there's no legal way you can get it
under under federal law but LSD LSD
heroin marijuana there's probably a
couple of others but the criteria for
those are it has to have a high high
propensity for abuse no zero medically
accepted uses and no chance that it can
be used safely under the supervision of
a doctor well marijuana doesn't mean any
of those criteria but but it's my
contention that that marijuana does not
belong on schedule one that if they were
actually following federal law
medical marijuana would be legal under
federal law so you're right about
marijuana all it's you you're the
marijuana expert at the Orange County
Register problem insofar as there is
such a yeah uh do you have you used
marijuana boom in the past and the past
and nothing to it didn't like it I
wouldn't say that now yeah why do you
think the government keeps coming out
with these reports that say marijuana is
going to lead to with dick other drugs
marijuana it's harmful there's no
medical benefit well you know once
you've got a restrictive law in place
there is tremendous resistance to
wanting to change that law why a lot of
people make a living at it you know I
mean there there is a drug abuse
industrial complex you've got the police
you've got the treatment centers you've
got the legislators all of the DEA of
course and in its a a 50 billion dollar
at least industry now all these people
you know have kids in college they have
mortgages to pay you know and marijuana
is the most commonly used illicit drug
you know if you just confined it to you
know heroin and cocaine and
methamphetamines and a couple of other
things the universe of abusers would be
much smaller and so you would have more
trouble justifying these large expensive
bureaucracies in order to keep our kids
safe less SWAT teams yeah
orange county's uh you know when people
first move here they want to know what
the areas like that by baristas orange
county's the real Republican area in the
real right wing area how to get away
with being libertarian down there well
you know sometimes we get nasty letters
to the editor but otherwise people
tolerate us how do they feel when he
came up for 215 I think most people in
the community supported it Orange County
didn't pass it by his larger margin as
the as the whole state did but it still
got a majority in Orange County so you
know there's a lot of Republicans in
Orange County so there must have been a
lot of Republicans have voted for it and
you know how you know how how I
described libertarians I say there that
they're conservatives who still get high
that's a little boy I don't know if
that's a universal no definition